[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم نبدا المنتصف بهذا الخبر
العاجل فقد فلت وسائل الاعلام الايرانيه
رسميه ان ايران والسعوديه اتفقت على اعاده
العلاقات واعاده فتح السفارتين في غضون
شهرين وافاد مراسل الجزيره بان بيان عوده
العلاقات بين طهران والرياض وقعه في بيجين
ممثلون عن ايران والسعوديه والصين ينضم
الينا من طهران مراسل الجزيره نور الدين
الدغير ماذا في التفاصيل نور الدين
نعم زين العابدين ربما هنا ما كنا اشرنا
اليه في المباشر الذي كان قبل هذا كانت
هناك معلومات صحيحه تتحدث على ان اصل
الكلام الذي صدر على النور نيوز يرتبط
بالعلاقات السعوديه الايرانيه الان تاكد
هذا الخبر وان ما كان يتحدث عنه مجلس
الامن القومي الايراني وهو اعاده تطبيع
العلاقات ما بين ايران والمملكه العربيه
السعوديه وهو ما تم الاعلان عنه في بيان
مشترك ما بين المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وايران وكذلك الصين لماذا الصين يبدو ان
الصين لعبت دورا المحوريا ومهما في هذه
النقطه الجوهريه وهي اعاده تطبيق العلاقات
ما بين ايران والمملكه العربيه السعوديه
ويمكن الاشاره الى ذلك على ان زياره
الرئيس الايراني ابراهيم رئيسي خلال
الايام الماضيه التي كانت الى الصين كانت
احدى محاورها ومحاور الحديث والحوار مع
الصينيين هي عوده العلاقات بالاضافه ما
بين ايران والسعوديه بالاضافه الى الجهد
الذي كان قد بدل في وقت السابق ما بين
طهران والسعوديه عن طريق بغداد وكذلك عن
طريق سلطنه عمان هذه المساله الان تتوج
بالاعلان الرسمي عن بدء الاجراءات لاعاده
تطبيع العلاقات واعاده العلاقات ما بين
ايران والمملكه العربيه السعوديه هناك
خطوات على مدى شهرين من اجل بدء هذه
العلاقات علاقتها بشكل رسمي خاصه بعد
القطيع التي حصلت ما بين البلدين اثر
الهجوم على السفاره السعوديه هنا في
العاصمه الايرانيه طهران في عام 2016
وكذلك الهجوم على القنصليه السعوديه كذلك
بمشهد الان يمكن القول بانها مرحله جديده
من العلاقات ما بين ايران والمملكه
العربيه السعوديه يتم سكها اليوم في بكين
من خلال بيان يشير هذا البيان على ان
المرحله المقبله هي مرحله لقاء على مستوى
وزراء الخارجيه ما بين وزير الخارجيه
الايرانيه ونظره السعودي وذلك من اجل
ترتيب اوراق واتخاذ القرارات اللازمه
لاعاده هذه العلاقه هناك نقطه اساسيه
ومحوريه يمكن الاشاره اليها على ان ما تم
التوافق عليه كذلك وهو اعاده تفعيل
الاتفاقيات السابقه ما بين الرياض وما بين
طهران سواء على المستوى الامني فيما يعرف
بالاتفاقيه الامنيه الم ما بين ايران
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه وكذلك تفعيل
جميع الاتفاقيات الموقعه سواء على المستوى
الاقتصادي سواء على المستوى السياسي او
سواء على المستوى الثقافي اذا كل هذا ياتي
ليتم الاعلان عنه هنا بكل تاكيد اذا ما
تاملنا نوعا ما في بيان او في ما نشره
موقع نور نيوز الذي هو بكل تاكيد احدى
المنصات الاعلاميه التابعه لمجلس المقربه
من مجلس الامن القومي الايراني يقول على
ان الحدث هذا وصفه بالحدث المهم لماذا
لانه بكل تاكيد ينظر الى الايرانيون على
ان اي اعاده للعلاقه ما بين ايران
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه سينعكس بشكل
كبير على العديد من الملفات ليست فقط
الملفات الثنائيه ما بين الرياض وطهران
لكن بكل تاكيد سينعكس ايجابا على جميع
الملفات او الملفات الاشتباك التي كانت ما
بين الرياض وطهران هنا نقص بالذكر احدى
اهم ملفات الاشتباك ما بين البلدين هواء
ملف اليمن يمكن بكل تاكيد القول بانه يمكن
ان يؤثر على هذا الملف والذهاب ابعد الى
وضع حد للحرب في اليمن واعاده العلاقه
وتطبيق
وضع الحد بالحرب في اليمن وكذلك البحث عن
حل سياسي يجمع الفرقاء اليمنيين وهو ما
كان يتحدث عنه الايرانيون في وقت كذلك
يتحدث عنه السعوديون ربما الان قد يجد
طريقه الى تحقيق بعد هذه الانفراجه في
العلاقه ما بين طهران وما بين الرياض
من طهران مراسل الجزيره شكرا جزيلا